Amsterdam is a city of contrasts one of
Europe's great cultural centers it's
also notorious for its criminal
underworld no wonder that art detective
Arthur brand has made his home here
he's been dubbed the Indiana Jones of
the art world but he insists his work is
closer to a less cool fictional
investigator if I would compare myself
with somebody it should be
Clouseau Inspector Clouseau because it
bit more successful than Clouseau
no Clouseau has always been successful
in the end as I am but the way to wit
its stumbling its following false leads
it's clumsy it's everything happens
three years ago he tracked down a stolen
Picasso eventually it was given back to
him by two underworld figures who turned
up on his doorstep who can say he had on
this exact wall a painting of Picasso
worth 70 million for one night and you
did I had one here for one night before
handing it over and I was watching it
and money cannot buy that feeling the
detective couldn't resist buying
replicas of the Picasso and another
valuable painting he recovered I decided
to make some copies and enjoy the rest
of my life and I can afford these copies
so mr. brand explained that he steps in
when police can't crack a case after two
years they have nothing and the
prosecutor says well first of all I
didn't like these paintings so let's
stop we have spent enough money and then
it's over and then I come in and then I
look to the modus operandi how did this
theft okay what did they do
what was their way of breaking it maybe
that gives me a lead and then I start
asking a route in the criminal
underworld the late Colombian drug lord
Pablo Escobar is said to have left a
huge art collection Arthur brand said it
does exist
it's the biggest museum in the world it
has everything a lot of fakes too
because some people some are dealers
even thought it to be a good idea to
trick Pablo Escobar
was Pablo Escobar a genuine
knowledgeable art collector or was he
simply laundering his money laundering
his money we always think of criminals
of being some kind of people with no
interest well you have them too but
there are some criminals who know
exactly what they're talking about a
month ago the detective recovered this
gold ring it once belonged to the
playwright Oscar Wilde it vanished 17
years ago from Oxford University but
it's thought the ring was stolen again
during the notorious Hatton Garden
safe-deposit raid it was handed over to
us in front of Hatton Garden exactly at
the same spot which is of course typical
English humor the Dutch detective
believes he's on the verge of another
big stolen art recovery one he hoped to
complete before his city's canals freeze
over
Martin Brant Sky News Amsterdam